o dia é é uma satisfação enorme e uma
preocupação um nervosismo também
bastante grande
eu vim lá de santa maria e aqui falar
com vocês
a maioria jovens mentes brilhantes a
contar a história é o gustavo me
convidou a conversar e embora é eu não
acredite que a gente transfira
experiências
as experiências têm que ser adquiridas
na vida de cada um desde que se nasce no
meio onde vivem as coisas que acontecem
vão nos formando por isso que é eu me
sinto bastante difícil de encontrar aqui
a minha história mas que sirva de alento
de meditação de a gente tem a onde se
fazer escolhas
às vezes não são aquelas que a gente
gostaria que às vezes temos que corrigir
o caminho para que a gente possa chegar
aonde for melhor
segundo as nossas convicções os nossos
ensinamentos durante essa trajetória
bom eu nasci em são borja 1º de janeiro
de 1946
depois de santa maria quando perdi meu
pai em santa maria
logo que eu vou vir para santa maria no
dia 31 de dezembro de 1959 13 anos de
idade
abusando e não respeitando os limites do
meu corpo o que a gente deve fazer
eu dei um mergulho na piscina a nota c e
bloqueie a quarta vértebra cervical
aonde fiquei tetraplégico
a partir daí tivemos que fazer bastantes
há muitas escolhas muitas decisões
algumas assentadas em outras não há onde
depois de um certo tempo eu fui parar
naquela época 1959 para 63
eu fui para em são paulo o instituto de
reabilitação do hospital das clínicas de
são paulo
de aí eu digo e opções e decisões que a
gente tem que tomar eu ainda com 14 anos
eu tive que tomar uma decisão importante
na minha vida
confesso a vocês é que estive diante
daquela situação é tomar a decisão de
viver ou não mais porque há o panorama
que se apresentava para mim
segundo os médicos lado hc de são paulo
era de ir para casa e viver da melhor
forma possível porque eu não mais
voltaria a andar e essa decisão
aí que eu tinha que tomar foi de
continuar vivendo e lutar mas eu pensei
sinceramente em terminar ali a minha
trajetória na vida porque era o futuro
bastante desanimador mas lá com as
minhas forças 4 com aquilo que eu
acreditava e resolvi continuar ea partir
daí que eu comecei então a formar nessa
escolha que eu tive a tomar decisões
para que eu pudesse continuar sendo útil
voltei para a minha cidade para santa
maria
voltei a estudar com dificuldades mas
voltei a estudar uma coisa importante
uma mensagem que deixa todos vocês
principalmente os jovens
a família e os amigos
é o são fundamentais para não só para
aquelas pessoas com deficiência que
precisam mas para todos nós
o apoio da família e dos amigos foi
fundamental para que eu continuar assim
a minha trajetória estudei tirei o
ginásio naquela época nem os mais
antigos aqui sabe o que é isso né
fiz o ginásio e o científico fiz
vestibular para engenharia civil a onde
passei três anos mas vi que não era bem
aquilo que eu queria uma escolha é
errada que eu fiz mas tive tempo de
convívio
aí fui pra olhar para seus contatos
reformei e passei a ser professor na
universidade federal da bahia onde
somente a oportunidade da época né
graças àquela época de transformação da
máquina de escrever para o computador
mac as pessoas mais antigos sabem dessa
transição
eu fui então chegando à parte de
computação a onde foi que lá na
velocidade a gente conseguiu montar um
laboratório
liguei támbém área de comunicação social
aonde fui professor também edição
gráfica e essa é a nossa trajetória na
universidade
na parte social a gente conseguiu uma
batalha bastante grande também desde
1981 e foi o ano internacional da
declarado pela onu como da pessoa
deficiente a gente começou então a
montar e lutar principalmente pela
acessibilidade
assim a sensibilidade
tudo parte arquitetônica a educação à
saúde né ao lazer coisas que antes nós
não tínhamos e fui também procurando
sempre ser útil foi vereador de santa
maria a onde a gente pode através do
poder legislativo transformar bastante a
nossa sociedade os meios de lutar
principalmente pela sensibilidade
eu tenho a dizer pra vocês que a luta é
água o que eu venho dizer pra vocês
contar minha história de de tomada de
decisão de luta isso cada um de vocês
sabe cada um luta nem nada é fácil né as
coisas não são fáceis para ninguém muito
menos para ainda mais nas pessoas que
dependem né de outras pessoas para
continuar vivendo
eu hoje sou presidente da apae depois
que trabalhei me aposentei na
universidade por tempo de serviço
certo hoje me dedico a apae de santa
maria a onde nós temos lá 120 pessoas
com deficiência intelectual da qual nós
damos lutamos bastante para dar uma
qualidade de vida é cada vez melhor
essas pessoas que muitos daqueles que
não têm aqueles nossos mas não tem nada
com aquilo que a gente faz é o de melhor
que a gente pode oferecer para eles
as pessoas que tiverem algum amigo ou um
parente que tenha problemas de
deficiência intelectual sabe o que é
isso
a luta é essa aí a gente conseguir
manter
eu tenho a agradecer à minha família
meus amigos eu gostava de convidou para
mim aqui com muita honra mesmo de vir
aqui o porto alegre falar sobre
a minha trajetória não é fácil
eu sei que cada um tem os seus
obstáculos e como diz a frase né eu
descobri hoje que eu não posso perder
tempo mais pra coisas que não valem a
pena
toco faz 69 anos agora 1º de janeiro né
então meu tempo é curto então eu tenho
que me dedicar às coisas que realmente
possa fazer a diferença
se de alguma forma foi nela que aquilo
que a gente pode transmitir
eu sei que cada um tem as suas
diferenças
eu agradeço agradeço a gentileza de
vocês eu me ouvir
é uma honra para mim estar aqui hoje com
vocês
transmitindo um pouco daquilo que foi a
minha vida a gente conseguiu fazer e
aquilo que eu disse lá pra vocês
quando tomar aquela decisão de continuar
vivendo
eu sei hoje da importância que foi nos
relacionamentos todos que eu tive das
pessoas que eu consegui na universidade
na vida os meus amigos
aquele relacionamento que eu consegui
transformar algumas vidas e ajudar para
que fosse melhor para a gente tenha eu
tive há a noção mais exata do que
significa isso
quando eu assistir a esse filme aí que
estão recomendando pra vocês
a felicidade não se compra então vocês
entenderem o que que é a ausência de
vocês no contexto social da gestão
vocês vão ver nesse filme que é a
felicidade não se compra da não vou
contar a história é toda mas ele pede
pra deixar de existir e o anjo faz a sua
vontade
e aí ele começa a ver todo aquilo que
era sua vida o seu
amigos a sua relações sem ele o que era
e que poderia ser então cada um de nós
eu posso dizer para vocês nós somos
importantes dentro daquele contexto de
nós vivemos as pessoas a família os
amigos tudo isso tem ligação com a nossa
existência
certo então eu agradeço a vocês de
coração por estar aqui e espero que
tenha servido alguma coisa - com relação
à reflexão e outra coisa
amem e respeitem o mecanismo que vocês
estão habitando ou seja o corpo de vocês
essa máquina maravilhosa
depende do respeito de cada um para que
possa continuar e fazendo aquilo pra que
nós vemos aqui nessa terra é fazer
alguma coisa mas respeitando
principalmente essa máquina maravilhosa
que é o nosso corpo
muito obrigado